welcome back the iconic neon museum is
introducing us to their next event duck
duck shed celebrating Las Vegas
architecture design and culture so here
to tell us all about it we have the
executive director of the neon Museum
Aaron Berger Aaron so great to see you
thank you so much for having me I'm
thrilled to be here so you guys have a
lot going on coming up at the end of the
month but tell us I gotta know duck duck
shed what does that even mean it's a
crazy name it is a crazy name so 50
years ago there was this iconic book
that was written called learning from
Las Vegas and in it we defined buildings
specifically in Las Vegas as either
ducks or decorated sheds so a duck would
be the perfect example of sort of New
York New York right you look at New York
New York and you see exactly what your
um what's inside uh the Luxor is another
one Excalibur a decorated shed is
um anything maybe on Fremont Street so
something that's going to need a sign in
front of it so that you know which one's
which so we played with the title and
came up with duck duck shed that is so
unique and very catchy and now I totally
get it
definitely memorable so you guys have a
three-day event coming up at the end of
the month tell us a little bit about
what's going on and plus you have a
special fundraising event in the middle
of it we decided that there's no time
for rest so we're doing um about three
dozen programs over four days wow um
these include everything from historic
walking tours to architectural tours of
the Boneyard to helicopter tours over
the city
um so we've got all of that wrapped in
with also a group of panel conversations
so we'll have leading Architects
International names that are going to be
telling us about what makes you uh Las
Vegas unique in its style and design how
cool is that and I was reading a little
bit online you have a list of everything
going on but if you just want to come to
one event here and there can you do it
all the car or how does it work
absolutely so everything is one off so
you pick what you like and you go to bat
and really quickly the fundraising event
you can actually go into the home of
what used to belong to Siegfried and Roy
correct it is the estate of Siegfried
and Roy and so what's amazing is these
two brought their cats home with them
every night and so this property has the
lion pens the tiger pens they're
incredible style all there it's going to
be a fabulous night well Aaron thank you
so much for breaking this all down this
is all
October 27 through the 30th be sure to
go over to the website and check out all
the events for duck duck shed thanks for
being here